time makes sense in small pieces but
when you look at huge stretches of time
it's almost impossible to wrap your head
around things so let's start small with
minutes hours days you probably spent
the last 24 hours mostly sleeping and
working with some coffee in there
somewhere
please watch less TV now let's look at
2030 relatively unnoticed Hitler's
bodyguard died at the age of 96
while in June Edward Snowden started the
NSA scandal moving back a bit the 21st
century is still pretty young and
largely shaped by the attacks on 9/11
that ultimately led to the third Iraq
war oh and Facebook and smartphones took
over our lives but we're just getting
started
let's back up further the 20th century
has seen its share of conflicts - after
two devastating world wars the Cold War
lasted for almost the whole second half
of it an average human lifespan covers
most of this stuff as well as the birth
of the Internet and the beginning of the
Information Age the oldest living person
on earth is currently in the cell okawa
who was born in 1898 which means that
her birth was closer to Napoleon ruling
Europe than to the current day the last
500 years of human history brought
enormous changes to our lifestyles
industrialization gave rise to new ideas
like communism farmers became workers
and knowledge became easier to
distribute the theory of evolution
changed how we saw ourselves and the
world we live in
a wall in a few hundred years the 15th
century was very eventful Columbus's
discovery of america and the fall of
Constantinople marked the end of the
Middle Ages people in the Middle Ages
were super into war over territory and
religion but the Black Plague was far
more efficient than war killing every
third European in six years arriving in
the Common Era let's take a look where
we came from our current century is tiny
and 2013 is barely visible this is
recorded human history the pyramids were
constructed 4,500 years ago the peak of
the Roman Empire was 2,000 years ago so
to the Romans the pyramids were as old
as the Romans are to us today history
starts with writing but what happened
before that about 12,000 years ago
the Agricultural Revolution took place
mankind began farming which gave rise to
the existence of cities and larger
communities the dominance of the human
species over planet Earth really started
here 90 thousand years ago Neanderthals
and humans coexist in Europe fun fact
this is roughly the time period a modern
spacecraft would need to reach the
nearest star Homo sapiens the modern
human evolved 200,000 years ago looking
at all of human history what we call ad
seems pretty small doesn't it six
million years ago our ancestors and the
modern chimpanzee shared a common
ancestor for the last time and for 2.75
million years stone tools were all the
rage a mere 65 million years ago the age
of the dinosaurs ended in an enormous
explosion which paved the way for the
rise of mammals but the dinosaurs ruled
the earth for an incredibly long time
over 165 million years that's so long
that it means that t-rex that lived 65
million years ago is closer to seeing a
live Miley Cyrus concert than to seeing
a live Stegosaurus animal life on this
planet started 600 million years ago the
earliest animals were fish and other
small simple sea creatures then came in
sex than reptiles and finally around 200
million years ago
mammals joined the party life itself
began much farther back 3.6 billion
years ago before any animals appeared
there were two point four billion years
when life consisted only of tiny
microbes countless single-celled
bacteria for 3 billion years all life on
Earth was invisible to the naked eye
it's hard to understand how
single-celled organisms could develop
into complex life forms like fish or
sloths
the answer is time a whole lot of time
2.4 billion years is a lot of time to
work with 4.6 billion years ago the Sun
was born from the remnants of a giant
explosion 60 million years later earth
formed in those early years frequent
bombardment by comets and asteroids
supplied the earth with large oceans and
a moon to send spaceships to but as far
as the whole universe goes our solar
system is pretty new thirteen point
seven five billion years ago the
universe was born and six hundred
million years later our own galaxy
formed from billions of stars but what
was before the Big Bang the truth is we
don't know that yet and maybe we never
will but we gave it some colors so at
least we have that
and there you have it the past now let's
take a look at what we know about the
future in roughly 1 billion years the
Sun will be so hot that life on Earth
becomes impossible the death of the Sun
4 billion years later marks the end of
the solar system ok so no more solar
system and what happens after that
a few trillion years from now star
production will cease and one day the
last star in the universe will die the
universe will turn dark inhabited only
by black holes long after the last black
hole has evaporated power universe
reaches its final stage something called
heat death nothing changes anymore the
universe is dead forever
now you're feeling some pretty weird
feelings right now aren't you we are -
it's only natural the good news is this
is all far far away the only time that
actually matters is now that cute girl
you like ask her out time is precious
make it count
[Music]